would you guys be down to do a real
quick skit a skit a skit like what would
be for the intro I don't know he why you
eating Donuts hey check out the 65y old
manine Donuts look at this figure not 65
don't say
65 why'd you cut it like that cuz cuz
first of all they're stale and they've
been here hey man who just who did this
they've been here first of all why you
need at the chocolate off the
top you did that who did that was that
your case no [__] who did guy who eats
the top of
the do you only eat top of the muffin
same thing I don't want the car they're
stale I love donuts we had them
yesterday this they taste like
Wax they're made gypsum and
wax all right man what sketch do you
want to do nothing never mind yes we did
we back at it again it's the figh in the
kid this is really the fighter in the
kid come on baby do it live good go yep
let's do it happy Halloween yesterday
everybody well h dress up yeah I dressed
up I have kids yeah I didn't I dressed
up as Ken in Texas but then I came back
oh dude I saw the Ken one
yeah what could you look any gayer dude
well hey does crowers go how can we make
Brian more gay they're like fellas
anybody like dress them as Ken but make
them was not that costume people and I
think I looked adorable there I
am look at that and I had tan tan on and
I had to get on my plane
that person got God they took my joke I
was going to say you look like the
gayest Chuck
Norris that's a gay Chuck Norris you
look like Chuck Norris is twink that's
really funny I'm the gayest Chuck Norris
you're the gayest Chuck Norris in the
world did you get a spray town uh yeah
they they sprayed me oh wow yep and I
look like Chuck Norris you do yeah it
look like a young Chuck Gay Norris I'm
not attractive and my gay my friend said
that to me he goes well you're not an
attractive guy he's dead serious I don't
know I I wouldn't say that but your
friend looks like [__] I don't I don't
think that yeah well you know so you
dressed up that but you didn't dress up
for actual kiddos so my wife was a
little bit lazy about Halloween for me
my son was dressed like a puppy dog she
was dressed hot she looked like a who's
the who's the Cruella or whatever
DeVille yeah she was all cleaved
cleavaged out and everything got the
tits out yeah yeah I was like
Jesus she goes is this good around kids
I go you're fine but it was just like it
was it was very hot and I um and then
she said you don't have anything but
Cody wants you to dress like a puppy or
a dog too so she gives me a white
T-shirt with a sharpie and goes draw oh
wow black spots and be a domination and
I went no so you did yeah I said you
should have planed better you should
have plan better yeah she said well you
know and then I said no no no listen I'm
not doing she goes well wear a white
T-shirt and black jeans so you match us
I said no oh wow you wouldn't even do
that cuz it's a little chilly out so I
wanted a sweatshirt on okay so I ruined
I ruined Halloween but my son had fun
yeah he didn't know what was going on
it's for no at that age they don't we
were we trick or- treated around the
neighborhood my original plan I was
going to be an alien and tiger was going
to be the scream guy but then my friends
at Prime sent me this new Prime drink
and they included two Halloween Prime
costumes and I was like uh I don't think
so and then Tiger's like Dad he he's
obsessed with prime his whole team's
obsessed with it I brought them gat
raade last game I thought they're going
to Lynch me they are not down for the
Gator dude yeah they're like loser and
they one stab me but was was was Joe uh
going as Mike Tyson who was your wife
going as Mike tyon the spider on her
face yeah no it's a spider okay I like
that though yeah but um so he wanted to
be the uh the prime thing he's like do
it with me so I ditched the alien we
went as the prime thing when I say it
was a hit amongst the kids bro oh really
cuz the I'm telling you that's how you
know Prime is a billion dollar business
yeah the kids dude everywhere prime
prime my son felt like a rockar dude you
can't buy those costumes so he's the
only one with it and has a device in it
blown it's a legit costume that's Logan
look your son look at look at uh Boston
Boston was dead serious as a zombie I'm
sorry is is Tiger he's seven is he um is
he 6 feet yet or because he looks very
tall there dude he's so
he made he made the allstar team he's on
the traveling Soca All-Star team what's
your son weigh uh what do you weigh well
you I think he weighs like something
crazy like 70b oh way heav than 70 daddy
he's 90 lbs yeah he's 90 PB he's like 88
at at how old seven okay I have a
12-year-old my son I don't think is 88
lbs right why do you do this it's just
interesting there are differences in
structure this what do you do this what
do you do this to me dude I'm pretty
cool man it's different right just some
people are buil for dance yeah right
some people are buil for dance or I
don't know other things like um other
things that are not that don't require
cut orange slices while the boys play no
no don't say that please don't say that
you can be very skin or gathering up
Gathering up the prime while the boys
are wor okay listen keep cold no you can
also be for acting you can bu buil for
built for poetry getting our popcorn
while we're watching the movie see I
don't like that I don't like that
because you can also be built for being
expressive gesturing being long you can
cheer on the team what you cheer on the
team hey I don't little r on oh my God I
don't like where this is going to okay I
don't like wig cuz it's bringing me back
to my childhood when I couldn't make the
football team o BR when he was 14 new to
the United States and I wanted to be a
football player and I thought I was
going to grow into what I thought I was
going to grow into I had goals I had
physical goals for myself you know big I
wanted I said well I'll just what I'll
do is I'll drink milk and eat food and
what I'll do is I'll grow into I'll be
230 pounds cuz your dad said you can be
anything you want to be yeah and also
you're told that so I'd like to be built
like Superman and all I have to do is
what do I have to do show up work
out well I didn't know anything I just
thought eat and work out and also that's
my destiny and you're just like you're
every body else and then I got there and
I went number one this outfit is very
heavy the shoulder pads like a little
uncomfortable a little uncomfortable
it's also New England so it's very cold
I don't do well in the cold and oh by
the way I'm 100 lb and was the coach
like any question like yes do have
caviar at halftime or I'm a little
confused yeah well I looked around at
the football team and I was on JV and I
went I think everyone literally is
heavier than me everyone and then I got
hit and it was cold and I got I got run
over by this guy and I went this is not
for me and it's the only thing I've ever
quit yeah I quit I played for um two
games I think at least you found a young
age a lot of kids like there's kids on
my son's old team he's it's over now on
his old team like I'd have to do be like
the the line coach or or uh referee
right or the UMP I'd be you know foul
whatever fair and there was a kid in uh
left field and like when there's
practice he he's like this mysterious
little kid he's an artist you can just
tell but his his dad's one of the
coaches he can just tell like the dad
wants to do dad dad's a big dude he's
bigger than me he played baseball he can
tell the dad's forc him to do it so
we're out there and I go hey buddy you
like left field and he goes no I wish I
was in Center I oh you like playing
center field is yeah cuz I don't have to
do anything okay and I went oh bud I
went let me talk to you man I said I bet
you wish you had like a paintbrush some
paint right now but you wish you were
drawn he's like yes I'm like tell your
dad that butd it's and here's the thing
it's all good dude yeah if you want to
do that I like just tell your dad if you
if you don't want to be here man you
don't have to be here that's right
that's right and you looked me went I'm
seven why are you so serious there's a
Sports Illustrated writer he wrote a
book called The Sports Gene and the
purpose of the book was really to say
look you you trophy dads and moms your
kid you may think you're going to put a
lot of work in you know so so speed's
something that you're kind of born with
so they did they did some research on
soccer players and the kids that were
really fast at 9 and 8 were really fast
as adults born with speed I told
remember it ain't going to change if you
don't one if you don't have the genetics
of to be quick or fat it's just not it's
just it's nothing you can do no it's
just there nothing you work with a coach
or whatever maybe your time down a
little bit but you're not going to it's
not going to make up make you fast it's
just you're born with that fast s muscle
or you don't have it that's right and
with tiger on this new team it's like
the best of the best and I was like no I
he doesn't know but I'm like oh here we
go maybe he's just another kid maybe
he's just the best on this current team
we'll see how this goes dude he's home
oh man he's home oh man and then his
last game he was playing catcher and
this kid throws the ball in the catcher
uh the catcher like you know like the
shinard didn't fit him right fits most
of so his knee sticking out and this kid
throws a fast ball right at his knee
whack oh no and his mom rushed I'm like
wait wait let's see how I respond let's
see what he do was here and all the
people Rush were like you okay and he
was just like kept going I was like okay
we got one here baby we got one here
he's got some great I'm I'm that trophy
dad inside you are I don't like to get
it out there but you know enough about
Pro Sports to know how it goes it's a
long I know yeah a lot of things have to
happen as long as he's having fun and
you'll also have him do other sports
right you don't want to have him just
focus on one sport don't they say that
yeah not you don't want them doing like
like I think the problems with parents
especially out here they have the kids
doing like six different things so
they're just average at everything yeah
so for Tiger it's like zero in on uh
baseball and he's on the Travel team now
he also likes it that's very important
obsessed with it obsessed we can't he
doesn't want to do anything else but I
and then he's going to start playing
football in January so whatever he wants
to do but I would all these kids they're
Beast these little dudes are such beast
and they're the coaches throwing so
they're doing uh Fielding they're doing
pop flies and Tiger's okay at the pop
flies he's still not 100% at it Fielding
he's pretty good but the hitting is
where that's his thing right hitting and
base run that boy can fly but hitting is
I'm tell I can't strike this little
bastard out man it would and I look at
the coach he's pitching I'm like pitch
is just like me my girl's like tiger do
all right I went wait till they hit
she's like gr just wait till they hit
she's like look at these kids I'm like I
get it just wait till he hits tiger gets
up and dude oh my God oh my God really
oh dude I hand eye coordination he can
slow the ball down I was so [__]
stoked I knew for the one the only thing
I had growing up even got drafted by the
Chicago Cubs yeah my mother told me as a
even as a little kid I was very aware of
my limitations I was very aware I could
read [__] really quickly I'd be like
hold on oh I'm not that's not I I don't
know how to do that that's not my thing
oh even at 40 I'm not aware yeah no I
just I'd be like all right just like
them no dude those are all s foot black
guys yeah yeah yeah you mean sexually
what are you talking about basketball
okay Sports dude um I don't know it's
cool and he loves it but we'll see who
knows dude who knows serious is on guys
huh two Texas well the Texas and
Oklahoma even in Texas I wasas God damn
it dude it's
Texas I me Arizona I me Arizona sorry
that's what I meant Arizona in Ariz oh
did you uh I was doing a ton of driving
with this truck project I'm doing so I'm
all over the I'm all over so SoCal but I
was listening to Rogan and uh Elon I
love when elon's on I just started it
elon's not from this planet you see how
long it takes to think about things and
say things you know why because he has
has to articulate it so we understand it
that's what he says but when he talk
it's almost like he's a robot like when
they're ordering pizza he's like yeah Jo
oh can we order some of those can we
order can we get some pizzas here I'm
like hey bro you're a billionaire yeah I
don't make 1% of your money I'll order
pizza right now everything is free and
yeah everything's free to him so he's
like we we can try some of that pizza
hair then you can tell he just maybe
just doesn't have like a lot of guy
friends he's just not but he's like
we're really doing it aren't we Joe this
is what guys do we order pizza and
you're like Jesus Christ what he said
yeah it's not a very good Elon
impersonation though yeah his his
Cadence is weird right it's it's it's
very robotic well feel like he doesn't
um he doesn't he doesn't open his mouth
much and and no that that's when he's
that's when he's dropping knowledge but
when he gets excited sometimes sometimes
he get then he's
like you
could well you could do you could do no
oh it's loud when he somebody shoots at
you you it's not a lot of things the
windows have to be fixed but if you shot
it you yeah he dropped some freaking
knowledge on there didn't he say that
Italy was going to let them use the
Coliseum to have his fight with
Zuckerberg yes oh he I didn't get to
that point in the he's still talking
about the fight with Zuckerberg he say
he no no Elon work on the trucks the the
the production of those trucks is not
going great it work on that dude work on
that and uh sardine pizza quit [__]
around with Mar that fight is over dude
move on we've all moved on I was
thinking about something about this like
Elon makes the reason we love Elon it's
very interesting because the world again
is divided into people that like Elon
and people that like zck I like Elon now
why do I like Elon I believe Elon sells
trucks things I can use and good product
you Zuckerberg well my car I drive drive
produ but but Zuck sells in a lot of
ways what mind control and he controls
my children's Minds influences yeah and
I I don't I don't think that's so good
for us no I I think I think the
difference is one's helping Society the
other's actually hurting it now I did
did he mean to develop this Facebook and
hurt Society I don't know but what he's
doing is not helping move Society
forward you know what I'm saying that's
that's how I feel I was thinking about
the difference body dysmorphia hate like
and I'm sure he's aware of that but at
the end of the day he doesn't care at
the end of the day like yeah like like I
I like a man who manufactures goods and
services and and that way and I think I
have a lot more in common with people in
a Tesla Factory than I would
at Facebook headquarters maybe but
remember elon's not a manufacturer Elon
owns the company he's the bra not put it
on the wheels he's a vision so he's not
that guy but I'm saying he he makes
something tangible that I that's useful
that I can use you know yeah he had the
idea for it
yeah yeah I don't it's just a different
wantang
with uh Zuckerberg yeah it's just not my
cup of tea no he's brilliant you need
people like that but with uh when Elon
went Joe goes how much do you think uh
Twitter X is worth and he was like well
it's you know I I bought it to save
Humanity like the direction was going I
bought it to save Humanity I went he
goes so it's Priceless I was like boom
there I was talking to Rogan and I said
what are you up to he goes going to do a
podcast I go who are you doing it with
he goes Elon Musk I was like that's
[__] that's [__] awesome
do you think um the [__] was I going to
ask you what was I going to ask you
there was a point to that story and I
missed it that's not that's not where I
wanted the story to end when he shot
when he shot the arrow Joe was like Joe
was like I bet he's wearing the wig he's
like I bet I could get an arrow that
thing then elon's like bet you couldn't
he's like Hey Joe I'll bet you a dollar
you want to go do it right now yeah and
then they go out there it doesn't work
yeah that truck is amazing for for you
know I don't like uh uh electric cars in
any facet but that truck's pretty badass
damn I want I want to say something guys
if you want the best nuts that are the
best for you that tastes the best I was
just cooking with that macadamia nut oil
my my wife goes this is so buttery she
said that it is buttery she ain't lying
it's the best thing to a high uh uh
smoke point the dog in the studio is
freaking out cuz we don't have macademia
that's for I know I love it but but the
try House of macademia you you spend if
you want to spend money on macademia
nuts it's going to cost you your house
payments house usually to afford them
but then house academia.com
TFK and maybe if you eat more nuts you
look like the owner well we talked about
it on here extensively the boy is fine
there's a there's a there's a really
really rich guy named Brian Johnson he's
he's obsessed with living longer and
he's done he's got doctors around the
clock and he's trying to stop yeah he's
trying to stop the clock and he's at The
Cutting Edge of science the one thing
that this guy does is he eats two hand
FS of macademia a day without fail and I
guess there's something the Omega 7
fatty acid he's cuckoo from macademia
nuts I think he's actually been talking
to House of macademia to our boy Brandon
about you know Macadamia so if you like
that guy maybe buy more nuts yeah
because he started out without knowing
about House of macadamia I think he
started out by eating macadamia nuts
that's all I'm going to say dude and you
can get a free gallon of macadamia milk
that's right a gallon when you macad for
your car yep House of academia.com
TFK just add the milk to your cart with
any products and use the code TFA
products like the chocolate covered
macadamia nuts the 45% uh macadamia nut
bars they got it all should go to house
on macadamias
docomo I want to watch sports and make
money do you want that's all I want to
do I like watching sports and make
especially on a Sunday dude I want to I
want to watch sports but if you tell me
I could make money while I you can do
that dude and I'm going to I'm be
watching sports in The Green Room when
I'm in Niagara Fall senica casino this
Friday and Saturday right outside
Buffalo cuz I'm going to be I me
November 9 10 and 11's really weird I'm
going to be at at good nights watching
making bank bro do with draft basketball
is back also you got the you got NBA you
also got the World Series popping Texas
looking pretty freaking good and they're
making a great deal it's an official
Sports spending partner the NBA talking
about DraftKings and new customers can
score $200 instantly in bonus bets for
throwing down $5 on the NBA win or lose
it doesn't matter you'll start the
season with an instant dub and with
draftking parlays everyone's got a shot
even bigger basketball wins stram
together multiple bets for the same game
or build your parlay across multiple
games for a shot at making your payday
even sweeter basketball is more fun when
you're in the action download the
draftking sports app right now use the
code fighter new customers can get $200
in bonus bets instantly for betting just
$5 only at draftking sports week with
the code Fighter the crown is yours uh
gambling problem call 100 Gambler or
visit www.1 1800 g.net in New York call
8778 hope Andy or text heny
46739 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling 888 78977 77 or
visit ccpg toorgle P responsibly on
behalf of boil scen Resort chaos licy
partner Golden Nugget Lake Charles 21
plus age VAR by jurisdiction void in ont
uh onario Ontario yeah Ontario bonus
bets expire 168 hours after ins issuance
see sportsbook.com draftkings.com
basketball terms for eligibility and
deposit restrictions terms and
responsible gaming resources where were
we getting at be when you're
like and he was saying that he was
talking about how Rogan I mean he was
talking about how Elon in his opinion is
one of the greatest figures of the 20th
century really ever you know one of the
greatest figures ever he's just such a
just such a Visionary but I think
brilliant but also the idea that you're
right like he was able to just buy what
is that buyx and expose what was really
going on um yeah and I think the left M
it oh that you you paid more no what
it's worth and he's like it wasn't about
the investment well we'll figure that
out it was about how it was harming
Society cuz you were silencing voices
that weren't in line with yours like and
he goes they would say it's a farri you
know app now he goes it's not it's in
the middle he goes but anything that
doesn't agree with the far left they
consider far right he's like it's more
the middle yeah I everybody it's whoever
takes control of the story how is the
story going that's what that's what
happens right so it's not about truth
anymore whoever can tell the best story
that resonates in especially on social
media yeah [__] a that's ex El was
talking about how it's uh bulletproof
you know how heavy bulletproof cars are
like rappers and celebrities do all the
time it I mean as far as gas fixed so
you can't so if you have a window can't
R them down yeah you can't roll them
down I didn't know that by the way yeah
it's but people that actually do uh like
they'll take whatever it is Suburbans or
truck TRX inter turn bulletproof it's so
heavy it's so expensive too and so heavy
like your mouth per gallon goes through
the freaking goes way down I'm sure way
down find out how much a bulletproof car
weighs the average I'm I'm going to say
10,000 lbs i' say between with if you do
the windows I'll say between eight and
yeah
9,000
1500 lb no 1,500 lb we out of your
vehicle
okay yeah 2,000 800 to 2,000 lb so let's
say so a suburb so let's say the TRX
probably 7,000 lb so if you put
bulletproof another two so 9,000 lb
that's a lot so much that's a lot that's
a ton yeah literally that in their truck
he said it's around 7,000 same as TRX
now you might do that huh because no I
wouldn't do that no most people don't
need that but if you could if you could
have an engine that was 10,000
horsepower with wings you would put I
would do that that's what you do I would
you may not fly but just so you have I
don't need a bulletproof but yeah if
that thing can fly or float sign me up
yeah floating would be good floating
would be dope people do that they
convert their cards so they can go in
the water you ever land on a sea plane
that's pretty wild I don't think done a
couple seems cool yeah you just it's so
weird you fly into a lake and you're
like we're GNA land in this Lake and you
and you do but elon's right he was
talking about how the movies uh you know
they always get behind cars and shoot
yeah so that's you know that's what we
know so I'd do the same if there's a
shooting Everyone Gets behind the car
now if you get behind the wheels so you
behind the chassis the frame you're fine
but just between the door and like
shooting you're shooting at me between
two doors I'm going to shoot right
through those doors I didn't realize
that either to said I'm like oh really
yeah Vin Diesel does that Tim Kennedy
told me that Tim Kennedy goes see this
cuz we were doing like tax iCal stuff he
goes you see this you're between these
two doors this is nothing this is yeah
you you're dead I was like what I got
two doors he goes doesn't mean anything
and then we shot through the doors it
right through dude there's a show on not
to change the subject from Elon but
there's a show on Netflix right just
remind me of there there's a movie on
Netflix called The Kill team and it's
with the guy it's with that dime piece
from uh True Blood yeah the Swedish the
blonde vampire he's the sergeant but
based off it's a true story so they're
in I think Afghanistan somewhere in the
Middle East and this team is you know
they're they're murdering like just
random afghanis like they find them
they're not doing anything you know
they're not set a bomb shooting at them
and they just would kill him and so one
of the team members was like this is
murder man it was like reporting it back
to home and then it it got worse and
worse and then eventually yeah there's
the real people there eventually the
sergeant gets life the guy who's doing
it the real story there's a book on it
so the real story the sergeant got life
and the kid who he got involuntary
manslaughter he got three years in
prison for murder psycho man that's that
uh that's a good thing they should go to
jail for Life yeah that movie will not
make you like discredits it discredits
our military and they're most guys
aren't like these guys are sociopath
unican yeah exactly they're just out
there to kill and get a free pass
[__] sometimes [__] get into
groups yeah they're everywhere yeah
they're everywhere yeah killing innocent
people I bet if you I bet if you crashed
again what's up crashed no no no I was
gonna tell you a story but go ahead go
oh I bet you're bulletproof if you drink
this magic mine well if I want to get
into Flow State and I want to rock and
roll I can't leave that if I want get in
a shootout mhm I'm going to take this
and I won't stand behind the door
personally I love the
taste I love it myself it's so good it's
health and it really does that's why
those guys you could see the uh
our boy shs and gigs I was I asked him
honestly I was like how does it feel
they're like dude I feel a difference
I'm like yeah yeah you're selling just
seems off
man me feel nasty you can't be selling
yeah it's like a like try this cuz I was
going to have one so I'm not going to
like I get it I get it weird you're
drink little green bottle yeah trying to
be a good host yeah like what we going
to show us chin oh no uh when you're
talking about the the bullets going
through the the doors I told brenon the
story before so I got shot at before
hell yeah so you did yeah gang that
doesn't surprise me I was never a gang
member but so one bullet came the guy
was like Point Blake like this close to
us [__] like like this right me to you
Jesus yeah so my window was rolled down
another Asian fell no it's a black dude
uh so the Bullet went to that was my
next
guest you know the little molding on
where your window like stops my window
was rolled down and it's it literally
the bullet got lodged in that molding
area cuz it was like molding then glass
then you know whatever so it stopped
stuck it got stuck right so if it went
through it would have went through like
damn dude the other bullets they went
through the back door through the back
door and through the bottom of the car
like no problem just just like butter
and it went through my friend's my
friend was in the back he had you know
jenko pants back then oh yeah I love him
he looked at his pants he had a hole in
his pants so he started freaking out
touching his got lucky we got super
lucky Super Lucky what was the what was
the why was he firing out yeah Jesus
there's a place called Westminster Mall
in Orange County uhhuh and then I did
look kind of like you know I guess
gangster I'm not a gangster by the way
but I looked kind of gangster so they
asked you know where you from they were
as we're walking to our car in the
parking lot they asked where you from
and just started to open so then no no
that's where you're from and I just said
like [__] you like what what are you
going to do and first problem and that
was fine nothing happened then we drove
and they started following us and the
driver who was a close family member of
mine who was in a gang oh he parked his
car and then walked straight up to that
car and said like what the [__] you and
then there's a guy in the back seat that
had a gun and literally pointed it at my
you know my family member's face and my
family was like [__] do it [__] do
it [__] he never did it so
finally we walked back and then they
came back and the black dude that was
driving how stupid is that it's no we
were younger it's so dum think about
that like all you guys lives could
change forever over where you from did
he catch the guy no by the way my family
M wondered to Chase and RAM the car I'm
like we were like no stop stop stop so
we made him stop from doing it but and
then yeah did you tell the cops or
anything no no what what are cops can do
okay well they got they got CCT TV they
can find this no this was in the while
ago dude yeah the cop like okay but
anyways the bullets could go through
yeah doors no problem through the bottom
unless you get one of those Tesla trucks
yeah I saw two shootings in Los Angeles
they missed the guys but [__] it ruined
it ruined my week it's so depressing to
see somebody try to kill someone else
shoting [__] where were you hanging out
at South I was I was in no I was down I
was on Vermont Avenue I was in traffic
and this is such a crazy story I'm I'm
in traffic and I just look over and in
this little mini mall kind of area a guy
he had I never forget he had a he this
Mexican guy had uh glasses on the back
of his head shaved head and he just
unloaded just unloaded a Glock boom boom
boom boom bo bo boom yep and then just
stood there and looked at it everybody
was out everybody was just looking at it
no one was running no everybody just
stood there right and he was just he
looked he assessed the damage and then
casually got back into a uh Honda like
Civic Civic crashing and the car just
there was two other guys in it and the
car just kind of drove away no one did
anything so what so I go I'm I like I'm
looking how close are you I look and I
go like this I'm uh I mean I'm on the
road and so
I'm 10 yards away 15 yards away less and
I and I just see it and I turn this way
and who's next to me a police officer
and I go to the cop I go did you just
see that and he goes he was talking I
goes sir did you see that he goes what I
was playing candy CRA that guy unloaded
a Glock into that guy's car and the guy
was over there and so um he goes what I
what and I go that guy those guys they
see and they were pulling out those guys
shot at that guy just now with a Glock
you're snitch dude the guy like this
yeah I know and the guy goes the guy
literally goes like this he goes like
this he was in traffic with me and he
goes and he picks up his thing and just
kind of radios but nothing happens
doesn't do anything then I come I make I
make a revolution I come back and now
people are out talking and there's one
cop car and they're looking and they're
talking to the guy nothing nothing
nothing but it depressed I got depressed
I was like you tried to kill somebody in
front of me I hated seeing that the
darkness man oh man that's not good dude
and then I I chase those guys down The
Story Goes On know you're snitch The
Story Goes On I chase those guys down
and officer did you see that he's all
yeah why did you why why did you go up
like this officer oh my God officer and
cuz I cuz I don't use my my voice isn't
grounded officer those guys did you
excuse me see those mean men those guys
just shot a into the car he went don't
be a [__] I said like I went like this
I go officer did you see that and he
goes what I go throw me your gun but no
one was running or anything no one is a
muscle no one moved a muscle no it's
100% hey not only did move a muscle a
woman went like this a woman watched it
everybody's out a woman no one's
sprinting nothing no one moved a muscle
everybody this woman went like this she
just looked the guy walked by her woman
was there no one moved you don't that's
not people don't run in that situ run no
I run no because what happens is what
happened to me you hear boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom it's over it's
over and you go like this you go you
hear b boom everybody goes like this
that's a gun and you go like this what
the [__] just like so you don't have
time and then he puts it away but in the
in the crazy shop instead all the people
are just like not nobody moved a even a
muscle nobody ducked because it's not
you're not expecting it it's out of the
blue it's [__] weird I I that that
was the weirdest thing but now like I
feel like we're so privy with mass shoes
and everything like you hear that my
initial thought let's run get the kids
out out of here of course but you so you
don't have time first of all if you're
in a car or you're a little bit farther
away and there's a lot of it's not as
loud as you so safe yes and you're going
to hear you're going to
hear and that's how long it takes when
you go like this you
turn if they start shooting again maybe
you're going to go get down or you're
going to be like i' assume they're going
to start shooting again yeah but you
don't move especially cuz he the
shooter casually strolled back to his
car
casually yeah weird [__] you're like
officer and he's like was it a white guy
oh no he's like we're good oh the best
is the best is where I lived in Echo
Park the reason I moved from Echo Park I
bought Dove David off's house a hot
second ago uhhuh and uh boom boom boom
we hear Boom Boom Boom Boom I come out
my buddy is working on my
fence and my buddy Bob he's working on
my fence and we're like Jesus what the
[__] was that that was a gunshot I said
that was Guns okay okay cool then we get
the cops come by these kids shot up the
street something happened there was an
altercation right by my buddy goes turn
to to [__] start his car it won't
start the [__] with my car can't
doesn't start my truck doesn't start oh
one of the 45 slugs was in his engine oh
damn yeah and I went oh that's too close
for home sir I'm getting the [__] out of
here you call the cops I sold my house
did you call the cops I was there for
three months sir you got in and out I
didn't call it cops cuz we didn't know
until he brought the car to the shop oh
they're like we found a bullet just
wouldn't start and they go hey dude you
have a slug in your car
yeah but you said you saw two
shootings now I I know I said there's a
lie somewhere in here no there's no lie
there it starts with this story I said I
saw saw two shootings this weekend I saw
I when I hold on when I said I saw two
shooting not this weekend this is over
the time I've been in La well you said
two I thought to
myself that I wonder if I did see two
shootings now now hold on I I but I in a
way outside my front balcony in on oh
God is this otherwise I don't want to
hear this was in 199 no no no don't care
I'm going to do me and the listeners a
favor don't give a [__] a guy was shot
right outside my window and I did hear
it and I saw the chalk marks but I
didn't see his
body now the question is Brendan if I
heard these shots why didn't I see the
body because I didn't hear the
shots but I did come home and I saw the
chalk Mark that counts hey speaking of
[__] did you watch uh Francis Fury
we you and I haven't talked about oh
dude you don't talk about talk about
this uh thoughts concerns thoughts or
this robbery I'm going to make some I'm
going to make some uh some St some
points number one greatest you put some
shoes on when you make these points or
no yeah I know I'm sorry greatest uh
usually I do greatest uh greatest
crossover uh athlete in some way in
terms of like that was the greatest
Jackson de S no no I'm saying I'm saying
comat sports that was that was CH your
words careful he was so poised he was so
patient fantastic yeah and I just went
talk about a learning curve talk about
learning curve and cuz to your point in
I'm not trying to interrupt you I'm just
trying to help your point out yeah in in
UFC he wasn't known as a technical
boxing in any facet that's why all the
history would point to it's going to be
a tough fight for him so that's where I
was like he needs to go in there and
just throw bombs hopefully connects then
he comes out I'm like huh what is this
and I was like there's no way who keeps
this up for two rounds then we're in the
seventh I'm like huh yeah what is this
because by the way you you went down the
boxing Rabbit Hole you worked hard at
it yeah Golden Gloves then you got asual
though but you got into you got in with
some really good boxers and you were
like oh Jesus Christ world class yeah
and you were like oh Jesus different
animal different animal you're like I
don't it's like going from skiing to
swimming everyone thinks because you
throw hands in MMA translates to boxing
it does not that's like being a swimmer
then jumping on the Snow Hill and be
like I can ski too anyone would say that
in in in in MMA anyone would say I got
in there with a world class boxer and
it's just a different thing it just is
there now there's some guys who can pull
it off like we on street is Strickland
[__] up some professional boxers maybe
but I'm saying you're talking about
world class boxers and you one would say
that's it but you're also talking about
this other caveat you're also talking
about heavyweight so there you go but I
I
like what what was just amazing is I I
went first of all I didn't know and Gana
was that big he weighs in at 272 and 25
it's so [__] weird so you're just
talking um but I I just thought and you
know people say he won I wasn't as
concerned I think he did win that fight
I think he kind of won that fight I'm
not mad that they gave it to uh to Tyson
Fury to say a robbery is a little I'm
always skeptical using the term robbery
do you see the thing I posted no this
where gets interesting cuz I gave inano
the fight and even before the decision I
went you're bat [__] crazy if you think
a crooked boxing commission the judges
that have a huge fight coming up in
December is going to give it to the MMA
guy it's not happening he' have to knock
out but if you see the knockdown again
I'm a casual if you see the knockdown as
far as I'm concerned you usually get 10
seconds to get up did you see how long
it was I did not I did not 24 seconds
what what yeah is that true yeah can I
see that sure can we bring that up
please oh yeah we can that's astonishing
it's on my Ig either way on IG either
way I believe it's getting flagged yeah
I'm going to make another it's getting
flagged because it's not my content it's
also not my original post it's uh from
bleed yeah oh they took it down is it
and refresh it did they take it down did
I get a strike I barely just opened it's
not my
content it I didn't do
it oh go go to go to just bleed let's
see if they took theirs off just bleed
uh jst b l e d oh sorry j s b l d
right it was the original one from them
and then go to oh they took their oh no
there it is see the see the yeah yeah uh
we we definitely can't play this if it
took it down though show up for Brian
and take it off the video let's take a
little break Brandon because I'm going
to be in I'm going to be in Raleigh
North Carolina October 9 10 and 11 and
I'm head up to [__] Falls dude [__]
falls this freaking Friday and Saturday
one show Friday one show Saturday at
Santa casino right outside Buffalo come
get you some Buffalo uh look with
everything going on in the world World
inflation War the economy right now
could be the best time ever to diversify
your money and savings with precious
medals like gold and silver gold silver
I bought some precious medals myself I
got them from the top rated company
we're talking about gold Co gold Co has
helped thousands of people place over
2.5 billion in gold and silver they're
rated A Plus by the Better Business
Bureau they've earned over 5,000 festar
reviews 5,000 they're a seven time Inc
5000 winner and that's just mentioning a
few of their accomplishments right
right now give them dude right now the
fire the kid listeners and viewers
they're giving you guys up to $10,000 in
bonus silver while supplies last $10,000
Jesus go offer go to goldco that's G
doco.com fighter tolearn more we don't
talk a l about money all right on the
show but this stuff is so important so
go to Gold Co gold cod.com it's about
diversification that's really what it
really is that's gold code.com
fighter so look at the look at the count
Tyson Fury gets 23 seconds after getting
knocked down so he got knocked down look
at the count he's back up though he's
back up oh no that doesn't count though
Brian the ref after look
ready so the ref starts cting now he's
counting to like he's going four seven
it's
eight so the count starts when you when
your knee hits the canvas oh boy
yeah man oh man though so so when so the
10-second count starts when the ref
starts it the ref starts that 10 count
after he gets up and when he's back in
his Corner then he goes ready one oh wow
two it was 20 seconds past
that so it's not it's not it do so it's
not 10 seconds as soon it's the the
count starts when the ref does it look
how long the ref took to give him the 10
count is the point I'm
making um that's true cuz you do see
that when you're on the ground they go
one well you see when they're down
they're going one two now the ref over
one two he waits till he gets up goes he
goes come on he's going six seven yeah
for sure I mean it's boxing dude they're
not going to give so Francis is fighting
the judges yeah Tyson Fury the best
heavyweight on the planet and the ref
I'll make a call he's going to if he
fights him in another 16 months or a
year um with that kind of learning curve
I I think uh Tyson Fury is in deep
trouble IE Francis was the champion
that's why I
disagree no the element of surprise is
over now like if he fights Anthony
Joshua Deontay Wilder or Fury again or
let's say usyk in some weird world the
element surprise the gig is up Francis
can box Francis boxer now oh yeah he's
not MMA guy anymore he's going make all
the money boxing he should stay in
boxing I correct he has two big fights
and MMA can't do any justice for him now
but the gig is up the the element of
surprise is gone now Fury knows he has
to train like he's finding a Deontay
Wilder like a c go he can't Fury didn't
train for that he looked horrible he
didn't train for that he looked even
Frank Warren was like I don't know what
that was that was Fury did not in any
faet looked like a boxer he's like I
don't know what the hell that was so it
didn't look like he trained for at all
the element surprise is gone everyone's
going to take Francis the most serious
so I I think it's going to be tough for
him now to get the win it gets the the
the difficult level goes way up now cuz
now he looks like a boxer he's no longer
That Awkward MMA guy now he's Bo Francis
andano has a couple things going for him
he seems to have a very very fast
learning curve he he seems to he hits
impossibly hard in these 270 lounds so
that's every heavyweight be no it's
really not I not like that and I don't
think anybody 270 is so big it's so much
bigger Dylan white was very big these
guys are big but Gano seems to have
something his ability to stand on the
edge of the pocket Parry shots he just
how do you pick that up so quickly he
might have always been doing it but this
is my point you know how and it just is
it is what it is you never fought but
you know how when you watch video you'll
watch a fight oh his hands are down man
cuz you're thinking of boxing mma's so
different so when I hear somebody go oh
his hands are down bro it's the the the
distance is different the movement is
different take Downs you're worried
about a lot of things the element of
surprise I think now the the gig's up
you know not saying he's not going to be
competitive or can win especially if
it's like a t like a Deontay Wilder
who's a little more less technical Fran
fight have big problems who deont Wilder
have big problems against Francis that's
francis's easiest fight yes yes yes who
else is there uh Anthony Joshua that's
what I want to say a tough one that's
what I want to say but is it a tough one
because Anthony Joshua will sit there
and trade that's what I mean Anthony
Joshua boxer now yeah Anthony Joshua
boxer Anthony Joshua also Anthony Joshua
one of the best 265 250 every bit of it
bit fine too yeah fine well if there's
one guy i' like to look at that I mean
that's I want to look like that guy and
that didn't happen for me but he's
fantastic but yeah he's he's uh he's the
fight I'm very interested in but but the
Francis won I mean obviously lost the
decision but he won cuz now it's not a
circus it's not a spectacle now it's
like oh no he went to razor close
decision with Tyson Fury your guys'
champ some people think he won M and you
guys can't beat and fury so no matter
what you feel about MMA Francis is here
he then I think the WBC said they're
going to rank France in the top five now
10 top 10 that's fair Francis and yeah
he should be top five but yeah they rank
him the top 10 so and now it because
anony Joshua on record going that's a
circus what Tyson's doing that's a
circus I want no part of it but you sing
a different tune now our boy box oh yeah
and we all want to see that oh usyk Fury
h I don't give a [__] nobody gives a
[__] and they also it's not happened in
December you know that they pulled the
card they pulled the fight why cuz FR
cuz Fury got beat up oh yeah that's
right that's why he he can't rush right
back in Camp so that's going to happen
in probably February March now so for
Francis and now what people don't
realize Francis contractually with the
pfl has to fight in March oh he does
pfl be cool man you side chick
now well I mean you guys don't matter
cuz we the bigger Francis is the better
it's for pfl I think they should allow
Francis to fight a Joshua or Wilder and
then and then he'll do MMA I want to see
that but if he let's say fights in does
he have to fight contractually has to
fight if if bfl you know put forces his
hand to it but on
pfl here's the issue if you it's MMA
it's different than bton in pfl in MMA
with 4 o gloves on at heavyweight
Francis can lose
let's say you give him some gnarly ass
wrestler for whatever reason Francis has
an off Knight can't land a shot losing
decision well that messes up the boxes
so we can't take that risk you got to
let him make life-changing money he has
two fights he could lose he could go 0
and3 in boxing and make 100 million
doesn't matter 100% so he has two fights
he's also 37 he has two fights that's
right so let's get those two boxing
fights out maybe one boxing MMA boxing
and that's it for Francis rides off in
the sunset Rich As [__] buys Africa does
what he wants to do MH mhm I agree
that's the smart that's the smart i' I
want to see Wilder and I want to see
Anthony Joshua have either one of those
guys called him out at all Wilder has
been recently seen training in with MMA
gloves on so I could see pfl doing some
insane deal where it's an MMA fight
because Deontay is not going to wrestle
France is ain't G to wrestle so it's a
boxing match with MMA rules not a good
idea for deont terrible idea terrible
you weigh you weigh 218 hey take my
money yeah take my money 100% want see a
dead body
you yeah that' be sick all see I'd
rather see Deontay Francis in boxing
Francis boxer bro that's where the money
at boxer that's right that's right yeah
man um it's a it's a one time Dana made
a mistake it's very rare he makes a
mistake and it doesn't and it comes back
to buy him in the ass it's the one time
Francis is the most relevant Combat
Sports Athlete on the planet and he's
not in the UFC it's the one time and I'm
with Dana business-wise probably didn't
make much sense it's the one time the
fighter won and if you're anti-man
anti-establishment you should be the
biggest Francis fan he bet on himself he
won in every facet and he's not
associated with UFC 100% he did what
everybody said was
impossible impossible nobody was like
why I think Kamar usman's there Izzy's
there you know when you when you watch
it I was like okay he's he's so much
bigger than I actually thought 272 so
massive so not going to be a to hang on
him he's stronger than Tyson probably
and then I went so he there's a chance
he could throw an overhand right maybe
even cuz he's taller than I thought an
uppercut whatever it is stuff yeah but
but he got him with one he caught him
with one in the close you know but I was
just saying all I'm saying is that I was
like I can see him connecting and he's
got a lot of you know a lot of strength
but I didn't expect that I didn't expect
that Poise he like fantastic either did
Bradley Tim Bradley was like what the
[__] is going on here yeah and even uh
like tripley was te I getting so many
text in the fight even after the
knockdown like me and Rogan are texting
I go Tyson's going to turn on here
though I go I I bet you Francis get fin
I bet I said I bet he gets serious I bet
he gets finished in the seventh or
eighth I said either way a knockdown
we've won MH seventh eth come around
like look at Francis doing the dam
Francis looks more like a box than Tyson
does yes yes insane
dude yeah insane most insane thing that
happened Combat Sports I will say that T
Tyson Fury wasn't doing the kind of
faints heed usually does he wasn't as
active on his feet no and the only
reason I don't comment on that is I
don't want to take away anything at
France State CU I know what you're
saying the way the world should work
we're in this upside down World in all
reality whenever a MMA guy steps up to
the best boxer in any weight class they
should get annihilated that's usually
how this should work so when this
happens we're in this upside down world
but when we say Tyson had trained Tyson
looked off didn't look like normal Tyson
you're diminishing what Francis did it's
the same with um Sean stricking is he
when you say ah is he's overtrained is
he needs a break cool Sean Strickland
beat the [__] on for five rounds so
don't take away what Sean Strickland did
no because what he did is insane what
Franc did is insane you can save that
other stuff for a later date y but for
right now it's about France about Sean
Strickland I think Francis and Ghana is
going to be the heavyweight champion and
I think uh I mean I I don't think
they're G allow him to you really boxing
doesn't want that but I want you're
dealing with the be you're you're
dealing with the most corrupt Prof
sport Francis the Superstar they don't
want it it's a bad look for those old
boxing heads hate MMA they despise it
but if if they can bring him over to
their family now he's a cash count now
it's like impossible still cuz you got a
lot of MMA guys watching and I don't
know uh I want to see Anthony Jos it
also messes up the boxing world like
usyk Fury as a boxing fan uh that's the
fight I've been asking about the fight
for how long now yeah and now it's like
all right so so so that's me so without
taking nothing away from Fran zanu if
Fran Sano and and Anthony Joshua are
scheduled to fight my guess is
reluctantly in your mind you're you're
you're you're still expecting even after
that performance you're still
expecting uh Joshua should not unless
this upside down world yeah but you know
what I'm saying even even after I saw
that amazing you give him more of a shot
though more of a shot it's not going to
be a cakewalk for anybody I still don't
feel let's put it this way I Francis G
amazing did The Impossible if he's
fighting Joshua I'm not putting money on
Francis I'm still I'm still nervous
that's the way we're wired though I got
I'm like and here's what's interesting
nobody's talking about this just so
everyone's aware usyk will beat every
one of
them he's so good and nobody cares he's
so good usyk barely cares usk will beat
the [__] of anybody we've mentioned on
the show today
and nobody cares you think us can can
handle that kind of size oh it's all he
he did with Anthony Joshua he dismantled
anthy Joshua twice Jesus setting traps
and no one
cares you think FR oh Francis sty was
awkward in Southpaw you think have you
seen usyk fight it's unreal nobody has
solved the problem no it's so un and we
don't care we don't care it's a such a
shame and he looks the part he looks
dope oh yeah he like crazy looking eyes
he's a muscular Andrew Schultz he's got
the same mustache everything else yeah
yeah Ukrainian schultzy the Ukrainian
Schultz and uh no one cares look at him
look at him oh he's awesome oh he's
awesome dude they had him jump in the
ring after go back to even the media was
like Francis go to the Joshua look at
how much bigger Joshua is seriously hies
oh that was a bad look for Joshua after
beat the shm he gets on the mic it was
even his turn what was he saying drunk
white chick at a wedding heill not your
day yeah he took that L hard God what a
stud with his awesome haircut oh look at
him he's got a sense of humor man oh
yeah he's a Savage Savage a sa beat the
[__] out of everybody beat the [__] out
everybody huh everybody look at Joshua
with was like look how much bigger he is
look at that oh yeah seriously oh yeah
handled them good Lord relax but that's
a big difference offre I know he's a
Cruiserweight he's a [__]
Cruiserweight natural Cruiserweight yeah
all right Chim what do you got since our
computer's scratching I know we got to
speed through this um let's see we got
to get to the
airport want to do this
one oh this is interesting yeah let's do
this one all right
so what happened so Joe Smith a 16-year
veteran of the NBA found out his wife
has and only fans and there's a cute
little video of it and we'll play it
here why do you put
this so he's getting upset talking off
camera why is he talking away who's he
talking to he doesn't know she's filming
but before he plays Jin you know would
she was a porn star before they met she
was a porn star yeah you guys didn't
know this did you not she said something
like she did something before so she was
in the dark arts then you marry her
she's in the dark arts heavy on dark
she's on the dark arts she's super into
dark arts right and then you marry her
and then you're like what you start only
fan she's like yeah dude I'm still in
the dark arts the darkness never leaves
he probably making money yeah but he's
balling so he's probably like what the
[__] that's the attention maybe here
here's what's alarming is it's clearly a
private discussion she she's filming
well so I got I'm starting to get
skeptical Hipp promoting only fans I
think it's a really good way to promote
her page I'm kind of with you Bri how
would he not know let's just watch this
let's just watch this go back go back
it's a long video it's like 2 minutes
that's okay let me watch I don't like
how talking away from the camera I don't
like his slippers turn this up
all disrespect could me before you did
it that's [__] though that's [__]
up D I'm telling you that's [__] up
wait wait no no no C but you're not GNA
say [__] me or that's [__] up it's not
[__] up record me what the [__] you
doing listen it's not [__] up oh I
think this is fake too going okay look
so I have only fans page and he's mad
because he F about just to promote it
I'm with you guys that's all it is I
don't know that's a real conversation
let's keep going she she's not animated
she's not upset enough she's like no
you're not going to say [__] me my
choice my body my body my [__] Choice
your supposed to come to me and talk y
I've been talking to you about mad
things I've been cuz you like no you
slapped like no I'm not doing this on
here created one that's no solution not
in my book that's no you you knew who
the [__] I was when you met me before
before he's a bad actor too I thought
that I would never have to go back to
anything
like that's not the case after that
after that everything's supposed to
change everything did change no
obviously no it had to I had to do
something you still out there showing
your
body you still out there doing stuff
like this on camera you act like that's
the only thing that I do I have mad jobs
but they're not facilitating everything
that needs to be done so I got something
extra only fasy breaking me off what the
[__] come on with that it don't matter
what they breaking you off it's the
disrespect that comes with it what
disrespect couldn't come and talk to me
about it okay well yeah they might need
the only fans money with a fan like that
there's air conditioning one they're
having money
trouble that's what she's implying two
they have one they're having money
trouble this is all staged two it it
it's probably staged to promote her only
fans I bet her only fans goes up he's a
really bad actor not before then you
supposed to end all that [__] first of
all if then here's why here's the other
reason I smell um I got his skeptical
hippos if I find out you're recording
I'm not following you in continuing
discussion no I finally record I'm like
I'm not having this conversation on
camera yeah and then soon she puts down
we have the discussion but she's
literally going like this and he's kind
of cool he's like no I'm going to follow
you upstairs no this is [__] up yeah
so in all the years he played he
reportedly made like 61 million but he
only pocketed 18 okay not a ton
especially if he's bad with money and he
was a number one draft pick in 1995 oh I
have the last no no spend what his nut
is yeah oh yeah you spend that that
money goes real quick real quick and you
would know if your girl like Shan up B
Lambo like I didn't pay for that did I
she's like
no okay keep doing what you're doing
yeah there's and and he's probably open
to it open-minded who knows if that open
relationship like if she was a porn star
before can I get
some some pictures she's older woman now
she's probably yeah I'm with Brian I got
I got to do my research let me do some
research on what's going it's like First
48 let me figure it out dude yeah cuz I
can get to the bottom of this me too
what is that Britney Spear body cam
what's that oh no that's too long too
poor Britney she had to go pee she had
to go potty no she's going bad on my boy
JT get over you're together Justin
Timberlake OH JT sorry you guys were
together for three years that's a Li
wife and they were so young I know he
did this he's like [__] I'm married
with kids go away that's a older one
though right okay
Travis tea Travis only fan pics
someone's leaking them they're probably
all over the web
she's very
pretty just put younger or what I don't
know just type in only fan see what pops
up she was when she was younger she's
I'm sure it's going to be like well no I
mean people are leaking stuff I'm sure
whoa yeah she's got it going
on oh what's okay yeah she's got it
going on I was looking for something a
little bit younger you know but she
looks great now she's than a market for
this 100% there's a market so son tell
me to put in x xxx yeah do that you
might want to I'm not saying we should
but you yeah yeah go that oh jeez oh my
there's no way that's her probably not
probably probably not no proba not Le no
cuz why would he he's not involved in it
so well or no or hear before oh that's
right what am I saying and that did now
we were looking at a penis in an anus
there all right well no that's not I
don't know what hole that is something
it's all dark it's very dark I can't
figure it out it's all dark okay I'm not
I don't know what hole it's in I'm not
going to talk about that oh she's sexy
woman yeah she's cool yeah she's a sexy
woman all right that's like the main
picture I don't know
why yeah keep
going no I'm doing research I want to
make I got to do research here there's
some other you want to make sure that's
not her that's somebody else that's a
white girl that's not a small do that's
a pipe though that's her that's not her
that's that's a white girl no that's a
white girl no I'm familiar with who that
is that's not her that could be her yeah
there's a whole situation that's her
with DJ DJ Jazzy Jeff apparently
wow another one well we've seen enough
she goes balls deep yeah well there's a
lot of close-up stuff going on but she
did porn though that's that's old school
porn that that looks like that old porn
yeah it's all good that's cool it is
what it is is that it chin before the
computer crashes Budd you got to get to
uh some places yeah I gotta go I'm I'm
head to Orlando I'll be at the Olympia
if you're out in or Orlando come stop by
the rain booth and then Friday I fly up
to Buffalo then driveing into Niagara
Falls this Friday the senica casino one
show Friday one show Saturday with the
great Brett Forte those bad boys almost
sold out the truck show uh the debut
episode drops November 14th but we'll
have a bunch of more content for you
guys regarding the truck stuff can't
wait guys this no is it this weekend
it's uh no it's October no it's a
November 9 10 and 11 I'm at good nights
and then I go to Canada Calgary Canada
yuck yucks November 16 17 and 18 we'll
see in a little bit I'm in Chicago
December 8th 9th two nights only get you
some tiet thck boy.com okay kids love
you bye